I had just on the third show at the
funny bone in st. Louis it was the first
time it hit me I was about 12 years in
and I had nothing going on didn't have a
manager didn't have an agent I remember
sitting there having a beer and I was
watching the waitresses counting their
money and everybody smoking cigarettes
and I gone to the club like five years
in a row everybody looks older I look
older and all of a sudden this thing hit
me is like am i that guy that doesn't
make it my that guy and I had a [ __ ]
panic attack oh you can't have a 12 year
gap in your resume like so you dabbled
in accounting and then you told [ __ ]
jokes for 12 years you're pushing 40
did you ever occur to you to let go to
some comic who you respected and say hey
I'm in a real negative space I feel like
I've wasted 12 years of my life I feel
like if you do that to somebody you can
only do it to them one time right
because trying to talk somebody back
into their dream is [ __ ] exhausting
exactly I don't mean and I've got a rule
now it's like I'm gonna do it once and
the second time be like well you know
maybe you should sell cars math you know
you know what turned it around I just I
don't know I just kept doing it I kept
doing it I kept doing it and then I did
your show a couple is Dave Chappelle it
did your show a couple of times there's
two types of people that make it in this
business it's it's the oh my god you're
the guy like you step off the bus with a
piece of straw between your teeth and
they do just make it at 23 yeah and then
there's the guys the rest of us who make
it in our 40s